we're live
do I have enough battery I just realized
all right
on stage here take this and they'll turn
them once you get on stage
wait is it online
[Music]
see
you're alive on the stage we are going
to be it's not everyone should be either
with us today
thank you for tuning in
a few years ago uh I asked the team you
know if there's anything that you could
do or change like a bowel because I mean
GitHub they said you know it would be
great if we could
um get more contributors
not everything benefits from having
people contribute and so we invented the
commies
as kind of joke and now they're real
um and today we are going to award all
our amazing contributors
uh specifically from the last year
we're happening
um
all right
[Music]
thank you
again
[Music]
yes
and not only is he committing he's
refining oh boy
he leaves
he stuck with us
ten percent
thank you
he lives in China
in person but we really look forward to
the time when we could have to be join
us on stage and I hope one day in the
future he could be a contribute our
presentation
let's talk about some highlights from
Dean Lee's constitutions yeah so uh
unreal
yeah I just tagged the issue it's like
you want to fix that at this
and I woke up and he's like in the
different time zone so it is like every
morning at Christmas when we need just
drop some beautiful prns in their labs
sometimes multiple wow yeah in this case
has been working on a requesting
features bug fixes
thank you
all right thank you Dean Lee for all
that you do we will uh ship you
've asked her about it
I'm trying to
find them I don't know anything about
this man I don't know what he looks like
is it true he could be 10 people we just
don't know
true Mysteries
um
or her you know
we used to start up building his own
Papa Neo it's an opening issue and uh
we had to figure out that YouTube video
we thought it was at a comma two or a
comma three we learn to do that
real-time Ohio
oh yes and there's some more you can
hear you even the regular lunchtime
mystery picture yeah who is who is the
man behind you leave
um
so thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
there's Dragon pilot
foreign
[Music]
you're so funny
stage
[Applause]
so
um somebody's been really great at this
as soon as you see somebody in the
Discord kind of new channel influences
he really reaches out and asks another
route and just forces
thank you
[Applause]
hello everyone it's sunny here and uh to
anyone that's using funny pilot I'm just
going to imagine going to before
any issues or any requests that people
like just let me know you can always DM
me or just go to my physical server and
uh if you want to support a new car
that's
as much as I can and yeah I'm going to
be in this community
[Applause]
[Music]
so this next person uh you might have
seen them around
um
multiple people
we only see one here
this is
today
[Applause]
I know it was a track from Texas the DFW
area
I feel like Eric has been in the
community
people
do you have some words you want to say
I fight for the people
[Applause]
this next person
has been here I think before I don't
know
um
[Music]
okay I just have this one story I can
think of I can't do that that's perfect
but I just remember I was working on
this one problem with the General Motors
card
yes Consulting whenever we try to study
this in your community survey and I have
reached out to him even though he didn't
have the bar and they were going on
before because he comment interesting
and I reached out to him and I have all
the contacts and I needed
the uh already able to provinces that I
think we were from them they really it
was a really good job
here is
um yeah because you know that great
brand new building
[Applause]
oh
Mustang
and I really feel like no one is
everything
I think he has five how many is it how
many CWS do you want
currently five
and then me and my wife and then I've
got a garage
thank you thank you
tonight I truly appreciate all the
things you do for the community I think
there's a lot of click on the points
that's right
let's go
so I think Jason is the I don't think
he's certainly the oh proud contributor
who I have to review their PR's release
what I reckon that jcpr I'm already
ready for the first book and I have to
remind myself I got to do that fast
change tab keep checking out real quick
because I'm emerging information don't
put that responsibility on me
it's uh it's the best quality camera
thanks again dude
[Applause]
I think that's it for our lives
honorable mentions yes
maybe not a whole commonworthy this year
but if you see you and we're excited
about what we're doing and we appreciate
it
so we've got one who was previously
shouted out in a talk um he's big in the
GM Community he made things are pretty
popular sport that recently popped up on
our dashboard it seems growth he's very
interested in your data he'd love if you
upload it to them
yes
he's got some novel ideas
it's doing your car it's twasenko
[Applause]
um
[Music]
the joints is this or Discord Community
reaches out to the hundreds of
Discord remember matters
artists and similar ly and it's really
all that inspironment
that I can put together
yeah yeah something about uh so we
realized that he was like personally
picking people and asking them to upload
data so that he can see what's up and we
were like where where we have all the
data in the world so which inspired us
to create the data set I mean we were
talking about it before but never really
prioritized it
[Music]
that's exactly the kind of thing that we
encourage a lot which is like you can
hyper optimize something to work great
on your cars and that's perfect and even
if it's even if it aren't really
Upstream it because it's like super
specific to your car that is great I
mean that just simply it is more
developers to you know working over
pilot and doing your own cars and at
this time generic enough time you can
like stream
everybody everybody can benefit from it
but that's that's good that's like
amazing and we really encourage all of
you to look at your Vlogs and see what
you can say thanks thank you
[Applause]
but this next person is also not here
but he's well known in the driving
feedback Channel as uh replying to every
single person with a customized video
the route we're flying on here yes so
this is uh an awesome daytime
[Applause]
honestly you guys should do the same too
I try to be a good example
[Applause]
all right now we want to do a final
shout out for FL 2.0 members
any of them are here you want to stand
up
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
truly
again soon right
yeah well I got the F-150 driver yeah
um here we got a couple of members here
today
um you guys found the bugs
it's always great when we can ship this
stuff get some feedback
because it's
time around
and it was a lot more chill than last
time so really a little look at every
single report I think it was a really
great experience too every morning
on our code name cheese yeah it turns
out we don't drive nearly as much as we
thought so but you guys really
appreciate um
it's funny for him self-driving car
company Focus company
we driving we're very well
everyone lives close to the office and
we've been working so hard everyone's
driving a road trip I really appreciate
the community uh helping us it's
critical
yeah you guys uh
I think 5x came out again
yeah different environments different
cars and things like you know be part of
succession
yes yes we've got lots of new cars
canopy cars especially thank you guys
again you're formerly released from NBA
your previous experiences
[Applause]
all right thank you guys for tuning in
it's a real pleasure really
we really truly appreciate the
development community and the work that
you guys do it's really nice to see so
many familiar faces uh please if I
haven't met you I would love to please
come chat it please
um thank you have a great night
thank you